Now, this shot here that you're seeing is pretty good.
Fairly boring background and well-lit, the angle is good...
...and the sound and the connection is spot on.
That's what you want to aim for.
We don't want something too distracting in the background.
Otherwise, the person on the conference is going to start thinking, "Well, I like that sofa."
"I think I got that cookery book." And they're not going to focus on what you are saying.
So, keep it as neutral and as dull as possible.
They should be focusing on your face.
Nothing else.
Now, we know what to do,...
...let's have a look at some of the mistakes that people make...
...when they video conference from home.